17 yaşındayken tuttuğum günlüğe şunu
yazmışım
Hani şarkı söylüyorum ya ben bu
kardeşlerim Arkadaşlarım için de işe
yaradığımı hissediyorum ya demişim ki
Allah'ın bana bahşettiği Bu şarkı
söyleme yeteneğinin karşılığını ona
ileride ödeyeceğim nasıl ödeyeceğim ya
bir vakıf ya da Dernek için çalışarak ya
da bir vakıf ya da Dernek kurarak
ödeyeceğim diye not düşmüşüm yaş 17
karşıma çıktığında bu günlüğüm Aferin
kız dedim kendi kendime bakar mısınız
yani hani diyoruz ya tercihler tercihler
karar vermeler insan aslında geriye
baktığında Eğer geride bir şey
bıraktıysak ki Günlük tutmak çok değerli
Bu anlamda İyi ki tutmuşum o zaman diyor
ki ya Hiçbir şeye tesadüf değilmiş
aslında hep bizim verdiğimiz kararlar da
döşediğimiz saçların üzerinde
yürüyormuşuz Meğer farklılığı olmadan
Yıllar yıllar içerisinde Efendim
hep müzik var hayatında ama şimdi lisede
arkadaşlarım kardeşlerim benim oyunumu
izleyen gösterilerimi izleyen buradalar
ben böyle bir değişiktim bilmiyorum
sizler Şarkıcılık yapıyorum Çok etkili
etkinin böyle işte vakıflarda
derneklerde davet ediliyorum TRT'de o 1
numara bütün bayramlarda kimsesiz
çocuklar derneğine gidiyor mu orada
programlar yapıyorum falan filan fakat
bir şeyler bir türlü bir dondurmuyor
böyle yüreğimi zihnimi şurada hep bir
boşluk hep bir soru işareti hep
sıkılganlık daralıyorum falan yetmiyor
hep daha çok yapasım geliyor ama cevabı
ne bu Bu soru işaretlerinin Kafamdaki
gençlikle alakalı olsa gerek diye
düşünürdüm hep biraz daha devam ediyorum
Bakalım
Hacettepe Üniversitesi İngiliz
edebiyatında kazandım edebiyat okuyorum
hem de dünya edebiyatı ve Dünya Tarihi
okuyorum falan O da güzel eş zamanlı
TRT'de bir program başladı eğlence müzik
eğlence programı ve bana göre ülke
tarihinizin ilk örneklerinden biriydi
hatırlayacaksınız kendini genç
hissedenlere söylüyorum gençlere değil
kokteydi diye bir program vardı Sevgili
Ömer Önder'in sunduğu normal abinin
Güngör'ün yönetmenliğini yaptığı orada
böyle program solistiyim çıkıyorum
Sürekli her ay ben öndeyim önce ben
açıyorum programı falan filan ünlülerin
biri gidiyor biri geliyor 90'lı yıllar
sizin o bayıldığınız yıllar gençler
Doksanlar kimler geliyor kimler geçiyor
Allah'ım ben program sosisiyim ya
havamdan Geçirmiyor değil mi eğer işte
Kim bu arkadaş Çok yetenekli gidiyorum
Tarkan geliyor Ebru Gündeş gidiyormuş
falan farkında değilim böyle işte Kenan
doğulular geçiyor gidiyor Falan benim
Önümden geçiyor gidiyorlar Ben de
bekliyorum tamam mı efendim hayat
geçiyor Daha doğrusu sonrasında yaklaşık
23 sene kadar TRT'de programlar sunmaya
devam ettim o program sorisliğinden
sonra çünkü kendine geliştirmeyi seven
bir gençtim ben diksiyon dersleri de
almıştım O yıllarımda çok okumayı
okumayı çok severdim falan derken TRT
beni fark etti İşte bir bakıyorsunuz
spor programı sunuyorum ertesi gün bir
bakıyorsunuz Bilim ve teknolojide
ilerleyen aşamalarda diye bir program
sunuyorum falan bir sonraki hafta
Efendim bunlar hep de süreli programlara
devam ediyor Pınar Gençlik programı var
işte alpay'da sun sunarım abiciğim
gençler Merhaba diyorum Pınar cuma
akşamları yeni bir programa başlıyoruz
caz programı şarkı söylemeniz tabi Ağla
me falan böyle bir çorba halindeyim Ama
tabii kendime iyilik ve ediyorum kötülük
mü ediyorum kafayı iyice karışıyor bende
ama engelleyemediğim bir kefeyi
doldurma
hissiyatı var içinde ve hala diyorum ki
bunlar Neyime yarayacak yaramalı bir şey
olmalı geliştiriyorum kendimi falan ama
bir şeylerime yaramalı TRT'de böyle
televizyonculuğun artık kamera arkası
kamera önü yanı sağa sola öğrenmediğim
şey kalmadı diyorum ki o 23 yılda Belki
de iki üniversite bitirmiş kadar Basın
Yayın iletişim bitirmiş kadar hakikaten
eğitildiğimi gördüm inandım ona Efendim
Bu da o yıllarımdan son programımda
hafta içi canlı yayındı sonra Hani dedim
ya bu şarkıcılar sanatçılar albüm yapan
Önümden geçiyor 5 lira oluyorlar bilmem
ne
[Müzik]
düzenlemelerinde falan mı beceremiyoruz
bir şeyleri çok kaliteli müzisyenlerle
çalışalım ikinciyi de yaptık o da çok
şey yapmadı falan ama diyorum ki hep bir
şeyler eksik geliyor bana Yani insanın
şurası Eğer Tamam demiyorsa
Tamam olmuyor hiçbir şey gerçekten onun
Nasıl tamam dedirteceğini de yaşam
içinde bulması gerekiyor öyle bir
yolculuk bu yolculuk bana göre Efendim
derken az önce başlangıcını yaptığım
konu
meme kanserli kadınlardan oluşan
hikayelerinden oluşan bir koro kurmaya
karar verdim bir vesileyle onlarla
birlikte bir yolculuğa çıktık dünyada
hala ilkmiş var Onların yararına korular
şarkılar söyleniyor Korolar kullanıyor
ama hala
üyeleri hikayesi olan kadınlardan oluşan
Korolar hala yokmuş diyorum ya Hep bir
toplum yararına doğru gidiyor yavaş
yavaş yavaş yavaş o fanus su çıkarmak
kaldırmaya doğru gidiyorum
genişletiyorum alanımı kendi başıma
başladığım o iki buçuk yaşında başladım
yolculuktan yavaş yavaş başka yerlere
evrilmeye doğru gidiyorum Efendim işte
korodan görüntüler dünyada temsil ettik
Sonra Efendim kendimizi bizim orada
mesajımız erken tanı hep erken tanıdık
ta Sen petersburglarda yarışmalara
katılıp özel ödüller aldık meme kanseri
derken tanının önemini vurgulayan
çalışmalar yaptık 15 yıl koro olarak
devam ettikten sonra geçen sene
dernekleştikte hala çalışmalarımı
sürüyor çok yüreklere dokunuyoruz sonra
bir dönem
Bunlar daha önceydi Hatta arada kalmış
bu misafir şarkıları adında YouTube
üzerinden ki bu da çok yeniydi daha Her
şeyin ilkini yapmayı seviyorum ben sonra
ama devam ettirmekte sıkıntı yaşıyorum
ilklerden biriydi arkadaşlar YouTube
üzerinden 115 ülkeye ulaşabiliyorduk
canlı yayın müzik programı yapıyorduk
evde yapıyorduk Üstelik Bütün komşular
konuğumuzu Pijamasını sabahlığını giyen
gelirdi keyifliydi Bu da bir ilkti
kendimce yavaş yavaş artık kaldırıyorum
ya hani şu cam fanusu aşıyorum ya
Sınırlarımı dünyaya açılıyorum
venezuela'dan yazıyor
6 yıla yazıyorum
Amerika'dan Biz Türkler şu anda diyor
toplandık patronun odasında diyor kapıyı
da kapattık izin aldık diye sizi
seyrediyoruz falan nefis dünyaya
açılıyorum artık ulaşıyorum bir şeylere
yavaş yavaş mesajlarımı veriyorum burada
yine konuklarımdan örnekler derken
AVM'ler bize sponsor olmaya başladılar
dışarılara taştık oralarda yapmaya
başladık sonra program kırmızı ve evet
yavaş yavaş artık
bugünlere doğru geliyorum hep bir arayış
hep bir cevap bulma ihtiyacı Ne için
mücadele ediyorum nedir beni bu kadar
zorlayan şey nedir kozamdan çıkmaya iten
şey beni Sonradan biraz Biraz sanki
yolumu buldum gibi nasıl buldum Hani
şarkıcıyım gencim Arayış içindeyim falan
ya kendimden pay biçtim ya dedim Benim
bir şeyleri önce anlamam lazım tarihte
ne olmuş ya böyle bir köklenmekte zorluk
çekiyorum Böyle her rüzgarda biraz
Sallanıyorum bir kökümü anlamaya
ihtiyacım var bunun için ne yapmak lazım
okumak lazım okumak ne oldu bu 100 yıl
önce Belki de Binlerce yıl önce ama şu
100 Yılı bir anlasak Ne oluyor bugün ve
yarın ne olmasını istiyoruz geçenlerde
bir öyle bir cümle kurdu dedi ki
Geleceği tahmin etmek istiyorsanız merak
ediyorsanız onu tasarlarsınız
kurgularsınız dedi güzel Eyvallah Ben de
demek ki o yola düştüm okuyorum okuyorum
okuyorum okuyorum
yüzyıldan öyle hikayelerimize rastladım
ki Kendi ülkemizin hikayelerine öyle
insanlarla karşılaştım ki önce tavan
arasındaki çalışma Odamızı full
kütüphaneye çevirdim doldurdum
kitaplarla okuyorum okuyorum kulağıma
fısıldamaya başladılar neler öğrendim Ne
Sırlar ne acayip olaylar ne yok oluşlar
kayboluşlar Ne varoluşlar canlanışlar
Allah'ım dedim bana anlat diyorlar ya
anlatmam lazım anlatmam lazım Çünkü
kendimi de bulduğumu hissetmeye başladım
Tamam dedim oralarda bir yerlerde dur ya
Afet İnan gibi miyim Halide Edip bile
olabilirim biliyor olsa gör desem
Makbule ama Kara Fatma'ya bakar mısın
alabilseydim neler yapardım
buluyorum galiba At şu fanusu açıl açıl
inanmak başaracağına inanmak
yapabileceğine inanmak göreceğine
inanmak bir şeyleri değiştirebileceğini
yapılmışı var burada var ya Espri burada
yapılmışı var yapılmışı var o zaman ona
biraz kurcalarsam model alabilirim neler
öğrenebilirim Aa Kim bu ya Mustafa Kemal
Atatürk nasıl bir adam bu böyle Aman
yarabbim Ne fanus ne bir şey öyle bir
manyetik alan yaratmış ki öyle inanmış
ki başaracağına öyle odaklanmış ki ama
nasıl yapmış bunu çok okumuş çok
öğrenmiş asla vazgeçmemiş dimdik devam
ediyor çok kararlı
en iyi bilelim peşine takılıyor
paçasından tutuyor bırakmıyor filan
Tamam dedim ya model bu model bu Tamam
tamam eyvallah bende neler var diye
şöyle bir karıştıralım sanat vardı ya
kültür fena değil uğraşıyorum Aa
toplumsal duyarlılık da var fena değil
tamam üstüne gidebilirim üstüne
gidebilirim daha kimlerle karşılaşıyorum
Mustafa Necati ile
'ler İsmail Uçar okul modeline bakar
mısın köyün üstünde çıldıracağım nerede
bunlar 21 diyor Ah karşıda havuz İzmir
Kızıltuğ Ankara Hasanoğlan dibimde diye
görmedim ben bunu daha önce bunlar neler
öğrenmişler Aman Allah'ım iş içinde iş
için iş eğitimi ne demek bu Aa bunda
tarladalar akşam sahnedeler
bu ne demek Nasıl oluyor Allah'ım
çıldıracağım çıldıracağım öğrendikçe
keyife geliyorum öğrendikçe keyfe
geliyorum tamamlandığımı hissediyorum ve
öyle bir an geldi ki sürem doldu
öyle bir an geldik Bunları dedim sahneye
koymam lazım benim TRT'deki
programlarıma son verilmişti
Öyle olunca dedim ki ben de o zaman
sahnelere çıkar anlatırım
başladım ya başladım anlatmaya bir kere
daha orada Duru verseydi zamanında Eser
çıktı ortaya
dursaydı orada zamanla Şu kötülükleri
yaşamasaydık ya da dursaydı da şu
güzelliği yaşamaya devam etseydik
dediğimiz anları anlattım derken
arkasından işte Mustafa Kemal Atatürk'ü
anlatır mısın diyenler için Kemale adlı
gösterim çıktı
siyasetçilere Efendim bütün topluma
öğrencilere öğretmenlere kitaplar hediye
etmeye başladım sahnelerde ettiğim
hediye ettiğim kitaplardan biri İsmail
Hakkı Onun için canlandırılacak kök
kitabıdır diğeri de gregory petrolün siz
söyleyin
Beyaz Zambaklar ülkesinde kitabıdır o
hale geldim artık kendim kendime
yetmiyordum da herkes öğrensin
istiyordum müzikle edebiyatla şiirle
cebimdeydi ya hepsi öyle anlatmaya
başladım tarihi hikayelerini sonra
Atatürk'ün sergi vapuru hikayesini
Bileceksiniz bilmeyenler 1926 senesinde
Lütfen incelesinler onu kitaplaştırdık
Seyir Defterine kitaplaştırdık her yere
dağıttık her yerde okunur hale geldi ne
mucizeler yaratmışız zamanında Her şeyin
ilki onu fark ettim köklerime
uğraşıyorum Aman ya ne bir keyif dedim
işte Kemal çıktı sonra
[Müzik]
bu müzik Ben Bu eseri 7 sene sahnede
çaldırdıktan sonra şimdi tüm Türkiye'de
çalınıyor Kıbrıs'ta da çalınmaya
başlamış
kompozitörü yazdı duyurdu Geçenlerde
oyunumuzda yayıldı Türkiye'ye bundan da
çok gurur duydum Efendim devam ediyorum
hızlandım
Mustafa Kemal'e anlatmak demek Aslında
bakarsanız Cumhuriyeti anlatmak demek
son yüzyılınızı anlatmak demekmiş Benim
amacım o değildi diğer kahramanlarla da
tanışmaktı ki Öyle de oluyor Onlarla
tanıştıkça dediğim gibi Kendimi buldum
onları örnek almaya başladım örnek
aldıkça da model yakaladım arkadaşlar o
model sayesinde de işte
Nihayet dedim ki bu kitapları okunur da
bu modeller öğrenirdi
el ele verilmez mi aynı Gönül'e aynı
yüreğe sahip insanlarla deyip tohumluk
Sosyal Yardımlaşma eğitim kültür ve
sanat vakfını kurdum Bundan 3 sene önce
öyle güzel insanlarla bir araya geldi ki
o kadar hızlı hareket ettik ki çünkü
aynı yüreğe sahibiz ya Aynı yolda
Yürüyoruz ve Alnımızda ışığı görüyoruz
ya işte o sayede hızlıca 3 yılda Bursa
İstanbul Kayseri Efendim Ankara
şimdilerde nerelerdeyiz eksiklerimiz
sayalım lütfen sevgili gönüllerimiz
mersin'deyiz Efendim Kayseri'yi söyledim
hızla
çoğalıyoruz ve İşte o kahramanların
öğrettiği her şeyi başta Mustafa Kemal
Atatürk'ün gösterdiği yolda yürüyerek
gerçekleştiriyoruz tohum diyoruz sanat
diyoruz kültür diyoruz Hayat köyde
başlar şehirle birleşir daha da
güzelleşir çoğalır büyür diyoruz Öyle
Kent arasında Köprüler kuruyoruz İşte
buna da başard
ve de başarmaya devam edersek
tamamlandığımı o zaman hissedeceğim bir
müzikle şarkı ile başlayan hikaye yine
müziğin de içinde olduğu sanatla
kültürle bambaşka yerlere geldi
manyetik alanınızı yaratın arkadaşlar
cam fanuslarınızı kaldırın manyetik
alanla çevreleyin kendinizi o manyetik
alan da başarının
ınıza İnançla oluşuyor çok çalışmakla
oluşuyor atomları hareket ettirmeye
başlıyorsunuz işleyen demir ışıldamaya
başlıyor ve İşte bu hale geliyorsunuz
son hemen tohumluk slaytımıza geliyoruz
bir şahsın yaşadıkça memnun ve mutlu
olması için lazım gelen şey kendisi için
değil kendinden sonra gelecekler için
çalışmaktır cevabı buldum buymuş aradım
Evet
[Alkış]
Cevabı buldumsanız da teşhisi
koyulursanız da tedavi çok kolay işte
tedavi Hani o müzik ne olacaktı hani o
Kültür ne işe yarayacaktı sonunda var
değil mi Evet
bu kadar benim anlatacaklarım cevabımda
[Alkış]
mümkünatak tohumlarına selam olsun
[Müzik]